baba and mid-suffolk are in the heart of
suffolk
covering over 1 400 square kilometers
more than half of people live in
villages or rural areas
building on our pioneering joint working
we have made the best use of technology
and use resources where they can have
most
impact for those most in need working in
a single suffolk public service hub
outside of the districts has allowed us
to build on the philosophy
that work is something we do not
somewhere we go
we have strategic ambitions and ways of
working
that enable us to connect into our
places support older and more vulnerable
people
and work with the energy and drive
coming up from communities and
businesses
to build more prosperous futures for our
market towns
this approach to developing an agile
resilient yet strongly customer focused
organization
has enabled us to deliver with minimal
service disruption
through the kovid 19 pandemic we've
housed and supported the most vulnerable
through kovid 19
to be home but not alone working
collectively across suffolk to offer
a new local coven 19 app and phone line
to connect volunteers and those who
needed help our councillors have been
amongst the first in the country to
deliver online committee meetings
we've pushed forward with our ambitions
for places and supported our economy
our joint local plan work has continued
to create the blueprint for our places
our vision for stone market has taken a
major step forward
with the announcement of a partner to
deliver gateway 14
which will in turn deliver a
multi-million pound boost for
mid-suffolk
especially the growth of creative and
technology businesses
while also maximizing opportunities for
inward investment
job creation and wider community
benefits
our vision for sudbury evolved in
response to covet 19
with the opening of its virtual high
street to help connect shoppers with the
high street
from the comfort of their own homes our
old headquarters sites are now
delivering for our communities
as part of our vision for needham market
creating new homes
community facilities and a boost for the
local economy
set to help the towns a post covered 19
recovery
we are supporting vulnerable people to
access good quality homes in the private
rented sector
central suffolk lettings was developed
by the councils
to increase access to homes for eligible
residents
and provide a letting service to private
sector landlords
we celebrated business innovation
holding our first
innovation awards in a virtual format
we recognized it had been a challenging
year for businesses
many of whom had to adapt and change
their way of working
to overcome the restrictions caused by
covid19
we have embraced technology and made
improvements for our customers
launching chat box technology and
started business process
re-engineering to improve customer
experience
our employees have appreciated the
supportive approach of the councils
and arisen to the challenge of kovit 19
magnificently
we are a strongly value driven
organization
they are our dna one of the last
in-person events
in early 2020 was our high five staff
awards evening
designed to showcase examples of
employees living our values
in 2020 our agile enabled teams
showed resilience and relentless focus
to deliver for our people and places
we are now determined to build on
positive changes made in response to the
challenges of kovid 19
and build even stronger and more
connected communities during 2021
at the end of the day we're all about
preserving what's fantastic in babur and
mid-suffolk
making bright futures for all of our
residents and ensuring that everyone is
proud to call us home
you